[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torre sánchez y los
acompaño desde casa a causa de la
pandemia de kobe 19 iniciamos hablando
de vacunación porque pese a algunos
obstáculos las inoculaciones avanzan en
el mundo los fármacos fueron probados
inicialmente en mayores de edad que son
los más propensos a contagiarse con kobe
19 pero los científicos explican que
para acabar con la pandemia los niños y
adolescentes también deben ser vacunados
justamente pzifer y variante que
anunciaron que según los resultados
preliminares de la fase tres de sus
últimos ensayos su vacuna 100% segura en
adolescentes de entre 12 y 15 años en
las pruebas participaron 2 mil 260
jóvenes y añadieron que se produjo una
robusta respuesta de anticuerpos
asimismo que los efectos secundarios
fueron similares a los registrados en
adultos e incluyeron dolor en la zona de
aplicación fiebre fatiga y escalofrío
principalmente después de la segunda
dosis
es una oportunidad especial poder hacer
algo como esto porque solo estoy en casa
haciendo deberes escolares así que
participando en este ensayo puedo ayudar
a otros niños a sentirse seguros ya que
quieran vacunarse en un futuro
recordemos que hasta el momento la
vacuna de faith serio a jon tech ha sido
autorizada en personas de mínimo 16 años
por ello este ensayo clínico era clave
las pruebas fueron anunciadas en
diciembre del año pasado y los
responsables aseguran que se trata de
resultados muy esperanzadores dada la
propagación de las nuevas variantes
asimismo que será clave la vacunación en
menores para reabrir de forma segura
todas las instituciones educativas
necesitamos que los niños participen en
estos ensayos para que sean protegidos
contra el virus los adultos no pueden
hacerlo por ellos fue una oportunidad
importante y estoy orgulloso de mi hijo
por aportar de esta forma otros
laboratorios como modernas iniciaron
pruebas en mayores de 12 años el año
pasado
astrazéneca comenzó en febrero un ensayo
con menores de entre 6 y 17 años
johnson y johnson indicó que tendrá sus
propios
pruebas y en china el laboratorio
sinovac informó que envió a las
autoridades los comprobantes que
evidencian que su vacuna es segura en
niños desde los 3 años pues fighter iv'
hay un tec también iniciaron su ensayo
en menores de 12 años en la universidad
de duke en carolina del norte de eeuu
las primeras participantes fueron
alejandra y marisol dos gemelas de nueve
años de edad y más exciting por pasión
the king fue emocionante pero también me
asusté un poco en la primera parte pero
realmente es fácil si te quedas quieto
durante la aplicación así será más
simple y todo va a estar bien en elche
televisión o en el ring genital
las pruebas son fundamentales para
determinar la dosis que se requerirá en
menores a pesar de que los niños que se
enferman constituyen una proporción
mucho menor a la de los adultos sólo en
eeuu han fallecido 286 por kobe 19 y más
de 13.000 han tenido que ser
hospitalizados según un recuento de la
academia estadounidense
pediatría
[Música]
a fin de cuentas para cualquier virus
como este y en una pandemia o cualquier
enfermedad en la que una vacuna es la
única opción para asegurar que la
población tenga un nivel de inmunidad
los niños una parte crítica los niños
son parte de nuestra comunidad y pueden
transmitir el virus creo que hemos
aprendido mucho de ellos pero en última
instancia nuestras comunidades enteras
todos los niños y jóvenes tendrán que
ser vacunados
unity ver si cambiamos de tema para
finalizar y se trata de una noticia
tecnológica y artística por primera vez
en la historia fue subastada una obra de
arte creada por un robot puntualmente
una robot hablamos de sofía la famosa
humanoide que hizo una obra digital
llamada sofía installation y consiguió
setecientos mil dólares en su subasta es
un archivo mp4 de 12 segundos que cuenta
con elementos del artista italiano
andrea buen acepto
muchas gracias por acompañarme y
apoyarme hoy lo virtual lo real lo
imaginario y lo literal este tipo de
espíritu de creatividad y tecnología
trabajando juntos me da la esperanza de
que podemos resolver cualquier cosa
cuando alguien adquiere una obra física
es justamente esa pieza y en casi todas
las ocasiones la firma de su creador lo
que garantiza la autenticidad en el caso
de un archivo digital del que pueden
existir miles de copias la autenticidad
la da un nfc en español un token no
fungible que es una cadena de letras y
símbolos única registrada en el bloc
change una especie de libro contable
donde está registrada toda la
información de los activos digitales es
de nfc certifica que el archivo es el
original
hemos estado explorando la creatividad
de sofía pero realmente la hemos
desarrollado como una plataforma y como
un personaje más que como una obra de
arte realmente estoy feliz de volver al
mundo de la creatividad pura
y la cifra de la subasta esa cantidad de
dinero que su trabajo recibió es una
gran validación para este tipo de
proyecto creativo
así llegamos al final de este espacio
pero los invito a visitar nuestra web
france24 puntocom para repetir este y
otros programas gracias por acompañarme
[Música]